hegemeyer was counting on me to turn the
tide of public opinion and ignite the
outrage of my fellow students excuse me
would you like to sign my petition it's
about the university reducing your
science requirements less science
no it's to stop the reduction and keep
our science curriculum strong
are you hurrying off to tell your
friends
bend over thanks ben
no no
no
excuse me would you like to sign my
petition about keeping our signs
requirements strong of course if you'll
sign mine
to increase funding for the school jazz
band let's pretend we never met
i needed a new plan one where i could
reach the masses
the front page of the campus newspaper
was my best course of action i deployed
every weapon in my literary arsenal
humor so funny gravitas
so moving fear-mongering so scary
and last but not least heartfelt emotion
not where i shine i'll end on fear
the next day i got to campus early to
get a copy of my article hot off the
presses and normally i don't like
getting newspaper ink on my hands but
this was worth it
plus i had wet naps
where's my expose
i didn't run it
what why
you're blaming this whole thing on a
grand chancellor there's no such person
of course there is he's president
hagemeyer's boss she doesn't have a boss
she's the president yes she does and
we've been trying to fight him but he
won't budge
the grand chancellor well when you say
it like that it sounds made up
how would you say it the grand
chancellor
i've been had
not now i'm on the phone oh are you
talking to the grand chancellor who i
know doesn't exist just like your
integrity uh i'll i'll call you back
don't believe her
you can't just barge into my office and
you can't just lie to my face i can and
i did well i'm going to start calling
you president hagel liar and i think
it'll catch on because it's both true
and clever
look i know you're upset but you left me
no choice i knew you'd be a pain in the
ass about these cuts language and also
these cuts are detrimental on so many
levels not to the university look
my job means sometimes making very hard
decisions no i'm sorry that i lied to
you and if it helps
i didn't enjoy it yes you did yes i did
i mean grand chancellor
i really pulled that one out of it ah
bottom
well i can lie about things too
did i knock your papers on the floor
no i didn't
did i move your stapler no i didn't
oh did i break your pencil
[Music]
yes i did
hey
i still can't believe she lied to me
look
there's something you should know about
life
people lie
everybody pretty much
well i don't like it
not always a bad thing
when is lying good
like
when you're trying to spare someone's
feeling
oh i'd rather everybody just be honest
fine
the last thing i wanted to do today was
pick you up you said you were happy to
do it see
lies
not the worst
i think i need to stop blindly trusting
everything
probably not a bad idea
which is another word for liar and
nothing
[Music]
is more important than my ship
he's so darn good at it though
[Music]
i hear no snap i hear no pop holy
crackle
[Music]
full of lies
[Applause]
[Music]
why are you watching wrestling
they beat the crap out of each other
it's great i bet it's all fake does that
look fake to you
[Music]
okay it's nice to know something's real
[Music]
ooh he's bleeding please what
[Music]
do
[Music]
you